hi there Steve Kaufman here again it's a
bit of a overcast rainy Saturday
afternoon here in Vancouver my wife is
practicing the piano as usual in the
background today I want to talk about a
subject that comes up every now and
again and it's the subject of burnout
you know what do you do when you're
burned out you don't want to study
anymore
it came up actually on our format link
someone had said that you know how long
does it take to learn a language in this
case was how long does it take to learn
Chinese and someone was talking in terms
of years and someone else said well it
depends how many hours you put in a day
and then I said in my experience behind
Chinese I was putting in seven eight
hours a day but someone said well if you
put any to mop too many hours you get
burned out so I thought about this and I
thought you know I've never experienced
burnout when I was studying Chinese I
was doing it seven eight hours a day but
it was my job I was paid to learn
Chinese I was employed by the Canadian
government they were I was a government
language student they paid me my salary
I was expected to study the language of
course I'm gonna put in eight hours a
day and languages that I've learned
since then I've been learning
essentially on my own on my own time so
I'm happy to get in an hour or so a day
but I don't get burned out I guess when
I was studying Chinese for the
government I had a certain period of
time in which I wanted to achieve this
British foreign service exam but in the
other languages that I've been studying
I'm not under any pressure I do as much
as I want but if I had more time you
know I think I could put in 3.5 hours a
day and check for example because and I
think this is the key I'm not studying
the language so much as I'm gaining this
experience and interacting with the
language and doing interesting things in
the language in the knowledge that as a
result my skills in the language will
improve I think if I had this
my time trying to study and rista Diann
and relearn and memorize you know
grammar rules or tables or answer
questions or do any of this sort of you
know study type work I wouldn't be able
to put much time in it I would I would
just stop doing it so in that sense
perhaps I would be burned out but when I
look at my check now for example you
know I've I happen to go over to
Vancouver Island and in Victoria there's
a store there it's an online store it's
called check ebooks.com I think it is
it's it's a wonderful place to buy all
kinds of stuff and I've bought things
from them via the internet but I thought
I'm in Victoria I may as well go and see
and see what's there and because it's
nothing like actually looking at books
and so I bought a bunch of CDs and DVDs
and books so I bought a book here called
you know this one here okay Molly yeh
yeh eeny Cheska's Lewinsky short history
of Czechoslovakia room 1867 or 1939
now as I read I'm starting into it
there's words that I don't know but it's
very very interesting here you have the
austro-hungarian Empire you have the
german-speaking group who are basically
the if you want the colonial power much
like England was in Ireland sort of
thing they you know had expanded
eastward and dominated the Austrian
Empire eventually the austro-hungarian
Empire so they had the privileges that
German language was given you know
preeminence and so on and so on and
gradually the Czechs through the 19th
century start to achieve some
recognition of themselves as an
independent state and then you have the
First World War and now the you know the
shoe is on the other foot the Czechs
want to set up their own state what
rights are the german-speaking minority
the ones who've been lording it over the
Czechs and denying them their language
rights and trying to impose German sort
of as part of the whole german-speaking
Austral or Austria
you know and so you have these this
whole issue of how that evolves and of
course these are all things that I
didn't really focus on and it's true
that the german-speaking minority in
Czechoslovakia got the short end of the
stick and that might have contributed to
events leading up to the Second World
War but then again they had basically
you know denied or tried to suppress the
Czechs more or less for quite a long
time so it's very interesting I'm also
listening to other things that are in
interest I'm listening to daily news
discussions in check so I'm kind of
familiar with issues like corruption and
and and so forth that are hot you know
in the in the Czech Republic so that's
all interesting so everything I'm really
and I'm following the international news
I'm following the economic crisis in
Europe via the Czech media so it's
interesting when I get tired of doing
that I did find a very good book again
over there called Chesky croaked Zac
crook M which is you know simpler
material where I can get more of the
sort of everyday language which I heard
but I need to listen to it more and more
in order to be able to use it and it has
some you know the odd grammar
explanation which I don't mind looking
at especially as I become more and more
curious about certain things and so as
long as you vary it and do things that
are interesting I don't see how you can
get you know bird out when I was
studying Chinese I mean you know there's
so much there history literature modern
history ancient history I mean how do
you get burned out I think the key thing
is but you you you have a goal beyond
just learning the language if your goal
is just to learn the language just to
nail down these declension tables or
whatever it might be yeah I can see
where you get burned out because after a
while those things won't penetrate
whereas if you allow yourself to just
learn things and learn about things by
interacting with the language and
reading and listening in if you have an
opportunity like I also borrowed some or
bought some DVDs some movies but I can't
understand them yet without the
subtitles
I can't understand some of the dialogue
but basically can't understand the
dialogue so I put them aside that's a
bit of a goal now maybe two months from
now I'll be able to understand more of
the movies so if you keep it varied like
that as I say with Chinese there were so
many different things that I could do
with the language I I didn't get burned
out but I guess at the core of it all
you have to be interested in so you have
to do things that are interesting in
order to maintain your interest so I
don't to me burnout is not a problem and
if you want to spend less time at it you
spend less time I'm not under any
obligation to do anything with check I'm
doing it you know out of interest but I
guess if someone is at university and
they have to you know pass some exams
and they're sitting there trying to jam
or Ram certain declension tables or
rules into their heads yeah they can get
burned out
I still think those people would be
better off if they spent their time
doing interesting things with the
language and eventually these things
that are trying to ram into their brain
will fall into place so there you have
it burn out for me it's not an issue as
long as you're doing things that are
interesting and when you are less
interested or not interested you stop
doing them no burn out